Thank You Jenny so as she mentioned my
name is Kevin Chapman and I'ma put a
manager at peak today I just wanted to
talk about our view of growth and it's
about testing lots of ideas and some of
the principles and processes that you
can use ourselves to grow sustainably so
I'm going to use a lot of examples from
peak in my presentation so just as a bit
of context as to who we are we're a
brain training app on both Android and
iOS we have more than 40 games within
the app to train your cognitive skills
we're a free app to download but if you
want to access the full set of features
you need to upgrade to a pro
subscription for that so where what's
called a premium business model cool so
jumping into growth is testing lots of
ideas so to begin with I just wanted to
illustrate the point by showing you four
different conversion tests that we've
run in the past six months and I was
hoping to ask the audience which one
similar to what Jenny did which one you
think had the biggest impact on our
conversion rate so if we take them in
turn the first one was making the
ability to replay games in a given day a
pro feature now the second one was
reducing the price of Pro by 25% in our
top two markets the third one was
bundling add-on modules from our
partners such as Cambridge and Yale
University into the pros description and
the fourth one was showing a preview of
Peroni content so that users could
actually see what they're getting before
they buy it so and which one do you guys
think had the biggest impact like
d hang lock slide different letters
maybe for a show of hands cool 4b 4c not
a popular one for D Wow ok so that's
interesting because the answer was a
making game replays a pro feature
actually increased our conversion rate
by more than 50% which is huge for the
business and you can go further it
actually had a bigger impact on our
conversion rate than the last 10 tests
we did combined so what's the key
takeaway well basically you don't know
what's going to work and what won't so
the key is to test lots of ideas as
quickly as you can
cool so taking that on board how should
you approach testing in your company
well we think that before you test for
growth you need a great product to do so
with a great retention if you have a
customer lifetime component to your
business model if you don't have this
then what's going to happen well you'll
be adding more users into the top of the
funnel but they'll just be leaking out
down the funnel so you won't be able to
grow your business and you're going to
be looking like the leaky app there in
the bottom right hand corner so testing
for growth is by nature quantitative so
we also think that you need data
informed culture to test successfully I
picked out four things here that I think
we do quite well at peak which might be
useful for you guys the first thing is
just starting lots of team discussions
about ideas for tests or tests your
writing at the moment and we use slack
for that because it's very collaborative
tool now the second thing is sharing
test results we use Google Docs because
again it's very collaborative
the third is publishing dashboards that
everyone your company has access to this
is particularly useful when you have
funnels like your onboarding funnel or
your conversion funnel and last but not
least it's important to prioritize and
litter
because it's very easy for analytics
tasks to drop by the wayside as you're
building new features so our top tip for
that is always having an analytics sub
task for the main tasks that you're
testing cool but the watch out with data
is to be aware of the local Maxima so if
you follow data by itself that's very
easy
that's very good at helping you to
optimize what you already have but it's
probably not going to get you to your
global Maxima as a business for that we
believe you need a long term product
strategy and data is just one infinitive
that you should also think of testing is
not just testing features within the app
but also testing other things so I'm
sure something testing your in-app
messaging your email your push
notifications there are really very few
limits as to what you can test your
company and it's a good way of making
sure that everyone is involved in the
process so I thought I'd give you one
example of that we've run a couple of
really nice tests on the Google Play
Store to using the grade tools that are
available that so three tests the first
one was changing the short description
so it used to be one that was a simple
description of our app what we do and we
change that to the one that highlights
an award we received from Google last
year as one of the top Android apps the
second one was changing the format at
the iPhone for a more abstract
one-to-one with our names in it and the
third one was changing the color of the
icon from a light blue to a library so
three very small things which to be
honest none of us had high hopes for but
humility cubit sadly they led to a 50%
increase in the page you to install rate
so that's a hell of a lot more users
that we're getting in the top of the
funnel now and there were a lot of
learnings that we took from this other
parts of the business as well cool okay
so those are a few principles I'm now
just going to briefly mention how we
approach process so similar to Jenny's
diagram there's kind of six key steps
that we think are involved in testing
process
the first one is brainstorming ideas so
ideally you'll want to get ideas from as
many people in your company as possible
for that the second one is prioritizing
those ideas and to do this what we tend
to do is group the ideas by which part
of the funnel we're testing and then
within that we will prioritize them
based on the impacts that we think each
test will have taking into account that
you never really know which one's going
to work and which one won't once you
have an idea of what's test you should
then try and come up with the Minimum
Viable test for that so that's the
quickest easiest thing you can do to
either validate or refute your
hypothesis you'll then implement your
test you'll analyze the results and the
key one is really to learn from it so
you want to make sure that the next
steps are very clear that everyone in
your business understands what the test
was what the results were and you want
to think is there anything else that I'm
doing at the moment that this test
effects
so I thought I would leave you with one
thing that we find works very well for
testing it's to have a shared testing
spreadsheet we use Google sheets again
for that and I'm going to show it with
Jenny at the end of today but if you
want I can also share it with anyone
here in the audience and just come up to
me and I can send you a copy but
basically at a high level there were
five parts to this spreadsheet so the
first part is an overview of the tests
themselves so description the rationale
behind them the second part is
information on the segment of users that
we're testing the third part is
information about the control and test
split within that segment the fourth
part are the key KPIs for our tests and
the fifth bar are the results and the
next steps for the tests that we
finished so the reason why this works
particularly well is that when you do
big tests they tend to affect almost
everyone in the company so for example
people in customer service need to know
what tests we're running we might get a
lot of emails from users asking what's
going on with the pcap in such and such
so then having access this document
really helps it's also particularly good
because you need one source of truth for
all your tests one place that people can
come and and find out the information
and we find this a very easy tool that
everyone understands you know
spreadsheets are not rocket science so
this has worked great for us cool so
just to summarize then you can't be sure
what's going to work on what won't so
the key is to test lots of different
ideas in order to do this well it's
important to have a great product having
a data informed culture is also key at
the same time be wary of the local
maxima and make sure that you test
features not just inside the app we
think that having a lot of find
processes is very important too and that
shared experiment stock that I just
showed you is really one of our key ways
that we test quickly and effectively
[Applause]
you
[Music]